my name is Leslie McCarran my major is
art I'm a third year MFA student and my
hometown is Albuquerque New Mexico I I
wanted to give the commencement address
as a kind of capstone for three years at
Carnegie Mellon and as an artist you're
constantly looking for an audience and
so I thought this this is an opportunity
to pull ideas from my thesis and put
them out in the world the title of my
speech is Yumi and life long ascent and
the theme is about polymath II the idea
of doing more than one thing of the
people who are experts in more than one
area I hope that my talk will be an
opportunity for people to think about
using the total real estate in their
brain and the full use the full extent
of their skills and not just imagine one
job or one outlet for them as a human
being but the totality of of their
possibilities at the time I came to
Carnegie Mellon when I visited I
instantly knew an art project and so it
felt like a doubly good fit there are
these read posters in the library and
different different people from all
throughout the university will sit for a
portrait and and with their favorite
book so Courtney and I did a our own
read poster which is now in the
permanent collection of the library I
love the every day and I love perpetuity
so those are the two extremes and the
read poster is this forever
fixture in the library but I also made
these toothbrushes that just say they're
monogrammed and they say ask for what
you want so the idea of the everyday
encounter with a message like a mantra
is another form of perpetuity and
everyday perpetuity to me I love public
addresses and I had the opportunity
through the school of art to do a
billboard and I wanted something that
would it would be attractive to all
audience
is so I recognized the existence of a
360 5/6 day cycle and so my billboard
said if today is your birthday happy
birthday so it created a bit of a
monument and could could be an address
to every person over the course of my
time at Carnegie Mellon I've started
five small businesses the fifth of which
I will enact as I leave here so it has
been it has served my artistic practice
but it also fuels my future intentions
my big dream for the future is to start
start my business harvest it and be in
the White House by the age of 35